It turns out that one of the biggest culprits
of a lackluster complexion is stress.
I feel like everything goes back to that word, stress.
And these days, honestly, who isn't stressed out?
So today we're revealing how stress can mess with your skin
and how you can start to fix it starting right now.
Okay, so here to help us is renowned dermatologist.
I actually am lucky enough to go to her.
She is my hero because she's also a psychiatrist.
So we are talking about a lot of different things
that come together with great purpose with her
and she is just everything, she's here.
It's Dr. Amy Wechsler.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
I mean, Dr. Wechsler, I always talk about
how beauty for me really is
an inside job.
And I don't care what you look like on the outside,
if you are stressed, if you are toxic inside,
if you are miserable, if you are angry,
all of these things come out and a smile's better
than any lipstick you're ever gonna buy, period.
You are really connecting something
that I think is so inextricably linked.
Thank you, they are, because the mind, the brain
and the skin are formed from the same layer of cells.
So they have all these interconnections
and it works in both ways.
And so when we're stressed, you can see it on our skin.
There's a stress hormone called cortisol,
it's not a good molecule,
because it does a lot of bad things to the skin.
Increases inflammation which can cause acne,
also breaks down collagen.
So when someone says, "I just got this wrinkle.",
they're really stressed out
and it could age you pretty quickly.
It also causes the skin's barrier function
not to work as well to make our skin more sensitive.
So it causes a lot of bad things,
but if you can break the stress cycle,
you can undo all of that.
Okay, that is great.
And we have some VFFs here with their questions
and crystal is here with her first question.
Hi Crystal.
(audience applauds)
Hi all, thank you for having me.
For as long as I can remember I've struggled with dry skin,
patches on my neck, my legs, my arms, basically everywhere.
And with COVID, I've been super, super stressed.
I've literally tried everything.
What can I do?
So the stress piece, the problem is
when we're stressed out,
the skin's barrier doesn't work as well.
It gets leaky and leaks water.
And so our skin gets more dry.
So should try to do things during the day.
I don't know what your work schedule is like,
to get off of zoom and get outside for example,
because getting outside in nature
and getting a little vitamin G for green,
really lowers cortisol levels.
There's other ways to do that too.
And then there's a good skin solution
which is safflower oil.
I know that sounds silly.
The skin makes a natural moisturizer
called linoleic acid.
And when our skin is too dry, it makes less of it.
So there are two oils that
are linoleic acid rich, olive oil.
But if you put that in your skin, you'll smell like a salad
and safflower oil, which is odorless, essentially colorless.
And you can get it at any supermarket for like under $10.
And you just take a little bit, Drew let's try it,
and rub it on your skin after your shower
when the skin acts kind of like a sponge to soak it in
and you'll be amazed at what it does.
Crystal, what do you think of this?
And also I'm gonna send you a bunch
of safflower oil after the show, of course,
from me and Dr. Amy.
I've never used safflower oil,
but I'm looking forward to trying for sure.
I just used a little and my hands are completely alive
and I am not worried about getting other things greasy.
This is amazing.
Good.
Thank you, Crystal.
Thank you Crystal.
(audience clapping)
By the way, I would like to circle
back with you and ask you how that's going, okay?
Oh, totally, thank you, I appreciate it.
Thank you ladies.
See you soon.
Okay.
Next let's talk about breakouts,
because so many people have been complaining about maskne.
I think it's, you're on mute and I have maskne
are the two quotes of the last year cycle.
It really is.
And you're on mute is cute and funny.
The maskne's not.
Why are we all going through this new thing
that wasn't there before?
I'm glad you asked me that because everyone
is just assuming the masks are causing acne,
but why are we wearing masks?
Because we're in the middle of a pandemic
and everyone is stressed out.
I don't think the mask itself is causing acne,
I think it's the stress, there hasn't been a study showing,
Oh, masks cause acne at all.
You know when I used to work in the hospital,
we wore masks in the OR all the time.
No one ever complained about breaking out
under their mask, never.
So what do we do?
First of all, just know that this is an issue, right?
Just to be more mindful and figure out, okay
maybe I'm extremely stressed right now.
Look at your sleep patterns.
Look at ways that you can lower your stress level.
That's one and that's free, right?
Just to take some time and think
about yourself and be mindful.
And then there are a bunch of over-the-counter solutions
for acne, Salicylic Acid is great as a wash
or a spot treatment.
Benzyl peroxide is good as a wash.
So there's lots of things to try.
Some people try too many things though and get irritated.
So I say two over the counter products maximum.
Okay, so we'll have all of these listed on our website.
Okay, finally, Adeena is here with her skin question.
Hi Adeena, how are you?
Hi, I'm good, how are you?
I like your flower.
Thank you, it's summer right?
It is.
Adeena, what's your question for Dr. Amy?
Well, this past year, my skin has been really sensitive.
I'm sitting on zoom all the time,
I could see the red blotchiness and it's, it's just not
I'm not happy with how my skin looks.
What can I do?
I get it Deena,
I also have sensitive skin, Drew also.
And you have to be really careful products you use
on your skin should be fragrance-free and hypoallergenic.
If you're trying a new product, I say, do a test spot
like for three nights in a row, right in front of your ear.
Because then if you have a little rash that's okay.
But your whole face isn't reacting.
I've always loved tea and actually created a cream
for sensitive skin with Chanel that has silver needle
white tea in it, which has the highest concentration
of antioxidants, really soothing for the skin.
I also love to drink tea.
It lowers cortisol levels and relaxes you.
So we have some silver needle, white tea here, and
it's really awesome to put on your skin and to drink.
I don't know why that everybody who is
in skin is not also in the mental game
because my goodness they're just so hand-in-hand.
Anyway, I'm just so glad that you came here
and I hope this is the first of many,
because we are all looking for a solution pun intended.
We really are and tips and tricks like this
can be real game changers to our mental space
because we can clear our problems.
So thank you, Dr. Amy.
You're welcome.
Thanks for having me.
I know I call you
all the time when I have a problem.
Okay,
here and here.
Make sure to check out Dr. Amy's amazing podcast
that she hosts with her own daughter Zoe.
Am I embarrassing you?
My daughters, Olive and Frankie who you know,
they would say yes.
What about Zoe?
Oh, Zoe says yes too, though she's older now,
so I embarrass her less, which is lovely.
Oh, that's good and I'm always telling my daughters
"I live to embarrass you!"
(upbeat music)